okay
i'll pull up some of the smash footage
are you weeping yeah this is the
funniest thing i've ever seen in my life
[Music]
look at this perennial sword
[Music]
though
i can't tell that's a bit or not
casual and rich right here
[Applause]
like sound effects
that play in your head when you watch
this
[Music]
between me yelling i was like and dean
has one and that's when i passed out i
don't remember that at all i remember
yelling and the next thing i know i'm
lifting my head off of the table
that's creepy man i was almost gonna
just like keep it a secret and maybe
it'd show up in the video but i was like
because i didn't think anyone would
believe me i was like i think i passed
out i didn't really believe it
sometimes rand over exaggerates with
stuff and i was totally thinking like
oh he didn't really pass out like he
just kind of got lightheaded he legit
passed out my wife would be able to
explain it way better she's a nurse but
basically it has to do with your blood
pressure it's the same thing that it's
like if you've been sitting for a while
or especially if you've had like your
head down or whatever and you get up
really quickly one was probably diet i
hadn't really had much to eat i probably
had some caffeine in my system so i
probably had like sugar and whatnot and
that and just like tensing all the
muscles in my body as i'm yelling
and then
not getting enough oxygen immediately
after that because i continued into
talking without breathing
[Music]
um
[Music]
that's going in the video there's no way
it's not
oh that's my favorite thing ever i just
want this on an endless loop as my
screen
[Music]
[Music]
i know i know what crew cuts what is
that well it's a brand new vlog series
we've been putting out on
quarterdigital.com we've got like 30
episodes up at this point i think
daniel's been doing a really great job
editing them together and we have a
whole other show that we've been working
on called functional filmmaking check
out the trailer now we got a vlog about
it afterwards
if you love learning from us and you've
been yearning for a deeper dive into our
knowledge this is the perfect series for
you going to spend time with each member
of the crew and they're going to share a
slice of their expertise with you in the
first season of functional filmmaking
i want to teach you how to make a story
out of anything now the thing about
stories that are based in reality is
that they often don't want to be caught
it all boils down to identifying
conflict challenges fears expectations
they're all around us if you have the
skills to find them you can make a story
out of anything i want you to be able to
master any camera at the studio we have
gopros we have reds and we have
everything in between and we need to
make them all work together i'm going to
arm you with an understanding of digital
camera technology and color science
that'll let you take any camera
including the phone in your pocket and
get beautiful images out of it i am
going to teach you how to visualize
scientific concepts things that perhaps
aren't well understood but easy to
understand and to explain how to do all
of that i'll be breaking down my videos
and explaining the thought processes
behind them you might think the hardest
part about making these videos are the
effects but really that's like the easy
part the challenge is that there are
millions of facts so you need to develop
techniques to process that information
not just for yourself but in a way that
brings context and meaning for others to
understand as well i'm here to teach you
guys how to make a cg model look photo
real we're going to break down the
physical attributes that visually define
objects so that we can recreate them in
cg these concepts apply across all 3d
programs so whether you're new to 3d or
a veteran with some time to kill on the
weekend this class will open your eyes
to a whole new world i mean honestly
like you'll be going on a walk and like
looking at the ground wondering how to
recreate all these textures you'll be
staring at walls zoning out you know
during movies your girlfriend be
snapping trying to get your attention
but you're just gonna be transfixed on
the wall or on the ground and um
so if all that sounds like something
that you want to learn consider pledging
your points to functional filmmaking so
we can make the show a reality
[Music]
so functional filmmaking has been
greenlit and we're working on a lot of
cool scripts for this series but in
order to execute it we're going to need
someone who has
a really in-depth knowledge of our
studio an in-depth knowledge of all
these different expertises we are
bringing together and ultimately someone
who can shoot and edit this
so
i mean
i guess there's one person who used to
work here
that kind of knows all of that
carmichael's like the easiest person to
work with some people you can depend on
just to get something done
welcome welcome what's shaking bacon hey
daniel hey what's up
much
dude
it feels like when i first started here
welcome back see mike oh
what are your first impressions i mean
it's organized
all right studio three we got production
maine christian
running it over here we have the
corridor crew channel we got dean we got
nick we got chase
someone um
[Laughter]
and then over here vfx this is clint we
have ren
he doesn't even know what's happening
this is going to be matt whenever he
decides that he wants to come work with
the rest of us and we have peter
hey and over here we have node
griffin as well he's working from home
and we have not that works right over
here
she has one of my favorite desks here
look at her art and then sweet sweet
sweet
toby flenderson
is our office plant
he's just dealing with stuff right now
we're gonna love it water it nurture it
and he will get happier in time
it was weird to think that studio four
would get crowded but it did yeah cause
i remember back in the early days it was
like we'd have one desk here and then
like we made a run
daniel's work is really good oh thank
you
that means a lot coming from you well
today we're here to start working on
nick's episode basically how we make the
quarter crew videos the thoughts that go
into that the process we follow we've
never really shown what goes into making
a quarter crew video with such a
magnifying glass i'm kind of shooting a
bts of the bts
your brain wants to film the most
interesting thing when you film sam sam
is obviously the most interesting thing
so i have to ignore that and just film
nick filming the most interesting thing
so it's a little trickery of the mind my
favorite moment today was when there was
four levels of bts in the room
yeah because
oh headshot
me filming sam carmichael filming me
filming sam daniel filming carmichael
filming me filming sam jordan filming
daniel filming carmichael filming me
filming sam
we finally achieved the joke that we
have always wanted to do
and it's now out of control within a
single hour it got out of control
pump that
[Music]
oh god
i mean how do i feel when i worked here
it was less of just like show up and
work and go home it's grind grind grind
work work work the more time you spend
there and how much you do in that space
kind of bakes a place into
your memory it's familiar it's like when
you go visit your old school dorm or you
swing by your parents place talking
heads education talking about filmmaking
i've been doing it for years with these
guys and this is an opportunity to kind
of like push it i also like the fact
that it's funded by the fans themselves
you guys greenlit carmichael coming back
temporarily that's what you guys
greenland
the show has a chance to
try something we can risk an idea i
gotta make that good so that way you
guys keep funding more stuff i got a lot
of like script directing and script
editing to get done i gotta stay focused
and get the job done
my life has changed in the last 36 hours
so much
i'm super excited about this
[Music]
so while we're all still busy working on
functional filmmaking guess what another
show's already been greenlit called son
of a dungeon here's the trailer
hey everyone i'd like to introduce to
you son of a dungeon campaign one it's a
dnd series that combines everything you
know and love from our past series on
node but this time we're adding a
special little twist we take great
lengths to make elaborate hilarious and
above all unpredictable games mashups
made a gaming and robust character
driven collaborative stories we always
take great care to put as much detail on
the board as possible but even with that
there are still limitations which is why
we're going to be adding a new unique
approach to this series what better way
to see what's happening in the game than
to go into the game itself as players
above roll dice and make decisions
you'll get to see the results play out
in this miniature universe combining our
love of 90s game shows and visual
effects we're going to be creating a d d
show unlike anything you've seen before
i've been playing dungeons and dragons
for about 13 years now and what always
keeps me coming back to it is the
collaborative storytelling environment
as much as i can plan as a dungeon
master you can never account for what a
player will do in the moment that's why
i love dungeons and dragons so pledge
those points because we would love to
make this show for you
there's a really cool idea here so if i
can recreate the whole terrain in 3d by
photo scanning it i'm i'm hoping it
could look a lot cooler this is an
experiment no promises okay let's do a
test i got some pieces here and i got
some caves got some dungeons taverns
stuff that's got organic edges stuff
that has straight edges this is pretty
simple geometry compared to this this is
way way way way higher detail than
anything on here so i think maybe a
little test i'll throw like one or two
character pieces down in there and just
see what happens photo scanning no
motion blur no depth of field
like it takes all day
i'm using reality capture by the way
tracks the scene and basically aligns
the points in one shot to the next and
from there it creates a point cloud and
then from there it creates a mesh all
right this is gonna take like five or
ten minutes all right fast forward
it's actually pretty good it even got
the holes through the windows here do
you see that let's put a texture on this
boom texture now we wait yeah let's just
see hold on hold on i know don't get too
excited
this could still completely fail here's
the thing this looks cool but will it
stand up to like macro style shooting
like if i put the camera down in there
close up
this concept is very close to being
proven actually i'm quite excited about
this i like messing with 3d models this
is cool it's cool like
taking something that's in real life and
then
like recreating it and then being able
to do anything you want with it that's
the allura visual effects you know so
you can
bend reality and shape it to match your
imagination
the wooden floor looks great
there's parts of it that look really
good there's also parts that don't look
so great see this dark stuff here this
because it's in shadow and i'm like
re-lighting it so there's just no detail
here flip your light around to match the
uh light lighting direction when you
take the picture oh yeah that's a good
idea we probably shouldn't use octane
for this you know it needs to be a kind
of a little faster to composite how
about doing it in real
not faster we need to invent a workflow
that's hyper efficient and scaled to our
production style exactly how do you make
something look as cool as possible with
the least amount of work and that's
super important for a show like this we
need to find that like perfect balance
that would probably be the assumption
moving into this you should film
everything locked up on the green screen
see i think if we can figure out a
system to give us
motion from the green screen quickly
tracked into like after effects or like
you get your shot and whether you said
it by the way no you're right you're
right i forgot you're right now you're
just filming all of the phone using my
extremely fast you want to film me on
the green screen yes there's literally a
green screen right there the guys at fxo
made this crazy app for your phone it
lets you record video and it gives you
3d tracking data at the same time so sam
can feel me on a green screen and get a
real-time camera that's tracked the same
way so no tracking markers needed
anymore in the green screen none of that
oh son of a dungeon i got shrunk down
and now i'm out on set maybe i'm in a
tavern maybe i'm in a cave boy i sure
hope i find my plus one great axe to
help me not die it works we're doing it
we're doing it
i hope
i hope we're doing it
once again i got carried away here so i
rendered out one additional little clip
i want to actually send this to the guys
over at dwarven forge the people who
actually make these pieces that we're
using sometimes we'll make something
somebody else will see it they'll get
inspired they'll make something cool
then it happens again someone brings
over some new gear we test it out we
play with it we use it our resources
help inspire what we're going to do with
them you get a new tool it can do things
a new way it gives you a different
perspective on things this is a really
good way to show off what we're making
and a good way to maybe make the world
you're creating even cooler too i'm
excited about this i'm sitting on
vacation for two weeks i'm just sitting
there i can't wait to get back
and do some vfx tests
and sam gets into experiment mode on a
project it's invigorating and it's
refreshing the world the
responsibilities melts away the
deadlines the cash flow all that stuff
you don't worry about any of that and
you're just once again doing something
cool i'm just doing stuff and trying to
make the best thing i can having a buddy
to work on stuff with is in return you
just like playing
like it's such a great way to inspire
yourself you don't get to do it every
day but it still happens
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right yeah quarterdigital.com it's a
great place to be functional filmmaking
is currently in production we got the
set built up over there in fact if you
don't want to wait for that crew cuts
are already up and coming early next
year son of a dungeon i highly recommend
you subscribe because if you do you can
actually put your points that you get
from your subscription towards different
shows that you want to see become a
reality through our green light feature
i think it's pretty sweet on top of that
we have all this merch that you can get
right now i like this flannel thing we
also have this boss town t-shirt that is
one of my favorite designs we've ever
put out but with your website
subscription you get 15 off every single
item on the store that's right
quarterdigital.com crew cuts functional
filmmaking son of a dungeon coming out
soon but crewcats is already out check
it out now and in the meantime have a
happy holiday i know it's november